[music]
[applause]
Unfortunately, in many places the preparation of the
snow leopard was practically
exterminated, and when we started working in
2010 on that one, we could
n’t find a single
snowbat here for
two years.  was not
recorded without finding it then it began to
be noted a problem with all the
research followed by the snow leopard
that is now being carried out
methodological problem everyone works differently
as a result we have a bunch of different data for
different states that in principle
cannot be summed up
we are now going down here literally 200
meters and  we’ve had a photo trap there
for more than a year and we periodically
check it, but we’ll also see what’s on it
[music]
and when the water traps appeared it
happened relatively recently it was
such a whole leap in the study of the
snow leopard
because scientists have now been in the hands of
scientists  not only the traces that
used to be and the main dull main
and  Information about snowy boffin about
its indecent photo that we will find new
animals
but this will not say that the
number has increased it will
say that we will find new animals in
order to have effective methods of
conservation of this predator we need to know the
real picture of what is
happening to him now lume
[music]